Get ready to learn English with
Harry Potter and the Order of the Phoenix.
Really quick, before we get into the lesson,
I wanted to let you know that if you're new here,
every single week we make fun lessons like this one
so that you can understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Hassan, who says that our videos
are like magic for his English fluency,
and your comprehension and confidence
are going to increase a lot too,
just hit that subscribe button
and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey! I just wanted to let you know
that the most fun way
to increase your comprehension of natives
and confidence communicating
if our Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48-week course, you will learn alongside
the first two seasons of the TV series Friends,
with 20+ page PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle global community,
and so much more.
And, the best part is
you can it try for FREE right now
with our 3-part Masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here,
or down the description below
to learn more and sign up.
And I look forward to meeting you inside.
Hey muggle! Have you checked out
all of our lessons with Harry Potter yet?
If not, then you're definitely gonna wanna check out
this playlist after you finish this video
by clicking up here or
down in the description below.
Alright! I hope you had an awesome time
learning English today with Harry Potter.
And, remember — if you want to add
a touch of magic to your learning,
then you'll definitely not want to miss all of our lessons
teaching you English with Harry Potter over here.
And, now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww Yeah!